معنى الان ما بلده حوره في النقب مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سامري نرحب بك نجوان ماذا
تابعتي من حوره خلال ساعه ماضيه
نعم بطبيعه الحال هنا في هذه البلده
تحديدا يمكن القول بان
التهيؤ للاحتفاء بتخرج محمد العصيبي تحولت
الى خيمه عزاء هنا في هذه البلده اذ انه
وصل قبل فتره وجيزه الى هنا قادما من
جامعته في رومانيا
لترتيب بعض الامور النهائيه قبيله تقدمه
للامتحان الاخير في مجال الطب بعد ست
سنوات من الدراسه وكان من المفترض ان يعود
الى هناك في اقرب فرصه لكن يوم الجمعه
اراد ان يتوجه الى مدينه القدس لاداء صلاه
الجمعه
وظل لاداء صلاه التراويح هناك ولد يعني
ارادته بالعوده الى هنا تم اطلاق النار
عليه بدعوه انه حاول خطف سلاح من احد
العناصر شرطه الاحتلال هناك وهذه الروايه
بطبيعه الحال ترفضها بشكل قاطع عائلته
وايضا المجتمع العربي في الداخل الفلسطيني
ويقولون بانه تم او تعرض لعمليه اعدام
مباشره من قبل عناصر شرطه الاحتلال لا
سيما وان الشرطه حتى الان لم تنشر اي
توثيق لهذه العمليه رغم وجود منظومه
كاميرات مراقبه كامله لها في داخل المسجد
الاقصى وفي محيطه هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
هناك اضراب عام عام كافه البلدات العربيه
في الداخل الفلسطيني بعدما اعلنت عنه
اللجنه المتابعه العليا وهي اعلى هيئه
تمثل الفلسطينيين داخل الخط الاخضر
احتجاجا وحدادا على استشهاده وهم يرفضون
ايضا روايه الاحتلال بشكل قاطع لان الشهيد
محمد عمليا هو الشهيد الرابع والستين منذ
عام 2000
برصاص قوات الشرطه والاحتلال سواء كان في
مدينه او في الداخل الفلسطيني سمعنا عصر
اليوم رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو يتحدث عن هذه العمليه واصفا محمد
بانه مخرب وبان وبارك قوات الشرطه التي
قامت باطلاق الرصاص باتجاهه وقتله رغم ان
هناك تحقيقات شرعت بها الشرطه الاسرائيليه
في طبيعه ما حدث ولم تخلص الى نتائج رسميه
بعد الا انه سارع الى تبني الروايه الاولى
لشرطه الاحتلال هو وكذلك وزير الامن
القومي المتطرف
ادعى انه يجب او او دعا الى منح وسام شرف
لمن قام باطلاق الرصاص عليه هنا حاله من
الغضب الشديد في المجتمع العربي الفلسطيني
داخل الخط الاخضر لما يسمونه استسهال
الشرطه بتنفيذ عمليات اعدام للشبان
الفلسطينيين سواء كان من الداخل الفلسطيني
وايضا من داخل الخط الاخضر منذ بدايه هذا
العام استشهد 94 فلسطينيا في غضون ثلاثه
اشهر فقط منذ مطلع هذا العام في عمليات
قتل واعدام مباشره وفي عمليات عسكريه
نفذها الاحتلال في مدن وبلدات فلسطينيه
مختلفه وهذا ربما يدل على تصعيد واضح من
قبل الاحتلال بالعاده في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك يعتكف المصلون بعد صلاه العشاء
والتراويح لربط لاداء الصلاه ايضا في
ساعات الليل لكن قوات الاحتلال بدات تمنع
ذلك في شهر رمضان وتقوم باخلاء المصلين
مباشره بعد صلاه التراويح وربما قتل محمد
جاء اثناء ذلك ليلى الجمعه ازدهار من حروف
النقب مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري شكرا
جزيلا لك